il y a de la zumba dans l'air
ah non la zumba c'est pas ça du tout la
zumba c'est plutôt ça
cette activité déferle sur la France
depuis 4 ans à plaisir nous avons
retrouvé une trentaine d'adètes pour un
cours alors qu'est-ce que la zumba c'est
un cours dynamique où on utilise
plusieurs styles musicaux entre autres
latino
meringuer salsa dans ce oriental ou rock
la zumba a mis tous les rythmes objectif
numéro 1 se défiler dans la joie et la
bonne humeur ça change complètement des
activités de gymnastique ordinaires en
fait on fait des danses latino c'est du
fitness dansé et en fait on s'amuse
super bien c'est ludique on s'éclate et
c'est le relâchement c'est la détente ça
n'a rien à voir avec la gymnastique
classique cette alliance va dedans c'est
de sport je trouve ça vraiment bien
parce qu'on peut vraiment se défouler
c'est de la bonne fatigue et voilà après
les cours de Zumba on est hors je suis
fatiguée mais je l'ai fait j'ai fait mon
cours puis moi c'est souvent des
musiques elles sont très Nantes donc
soit entraînantes et amusant quand on a
toujours le sourire toujours de bonne
humeur surtout avec
c'est vraiment très dynamique et très
très enthousiasme l'association GV
plaisir compte plus de 120 adhérents de
Zumba dès 4 ans pour la zumbaomi jusqu'à
77 ans et plus pour la Zumba Gold alors
une danse parmi d'autres la zumba ou un
vrai sport c'est un vrai sport c'est un
vrai sport étant donné qu'on travaille
le carburant respiratoire on travaille
renforcement la coordination bras jambes
en avant en arrière latéral etc donc non
non c'est c'est du sport pour les plus
curieux le prochain stage de Zumba aura
lieu le 27 octobre au prochain